entonces bueno sigamos donde nos
quedamos estamos estudiando esta fórmula
intentando entender por qué corresponde
a curvatura es decir porque nos dice
cuánto se curva una curva y ya
estudiamos la parte del numerador y
vimos que corresponde a un producto cruz
el producto cruz entre la primera
derivada y la segunda derivada de la
función que parametrizar a la curva y
empezamos a entender eso porque vimos
que la función que paramétrica a la
curva sdt produce vectores cuyas puntas
trazan la curva y si pensamos en como
una punta de un vector se mueve al
siguiente la dirección en la que tiene
que moverse para que esa punta se mueva
a la siguiente punta se nos indica con
la primera derivada y cuando lo ves de
manera infinitesimal podrás entender que
esa es la razón por la que obtienes
vectores tangentes sobre la curva de
hecho tenemos vídeos que hablan sobre
eso
puedes verlo si tú gustas de hecho son
vídeos sobre funciones que nos explican
porque la primera derivada de una
función paramétrica nos da vectores
tangentes a la curva pero si dibujamos
todos estos vectores tangentes en un
espacio ese prima de t obtienes todos
estos vectores enraizados en un mismo
punto ajá y la manera en la que te
mueves de la punta de uno de esos
vectores al siguiente estado por la
segunda derivada y si tienes el caso en
el que los vectores tangentes están
girando que simboliza cuando tu curva
está girando este caso corresponde a
cuando la función de la segunda derivada
queda perpendicular como vector al
vector de la primera derivada y esa es
la razón por la cual el producto cruz es
una buena medida de la curvatura porque
te dice o te indica si estos vectores
son perpendiculares o casi
perpendiculares pero observa la fórmula
original de la curvatura la razón por la
que estamos haciendo esto con respecto a
la longitud de arco y no con respecto al
parámetro t
es porque a la curvatura no le importa
como para mí trizas la función si
imaginas avanzar por la curva muy muy
rápido tal que tus vectores tangentes
quedan muy largos eso no debe importar
porque da lo mismo si avanzas rápido o
si avanzas lento por la curva eso no
importa la curvatura siempre se mantiene
siempre es la misma pero ahora observa
el producto cruz
estamos tomando el producto cruz entre
la primera derivada y la segunda
derivada porque si avanzarás tu por la
curva al doble de la velocidad eso
querría decir que tu vector de la
primera derivada tendría el doble de
largo indicando que base el doble de
rápido ajá y de manera similar el vector
de la segunda derivada como el cambio se
mantiene también este vector de la
segunda derivada tendrá el doble del
tamaño y como resultado el paralelogramo
que forman tendrá cuatro veces el tamaño
porque recuerda que ambos vectores
subieron de escala
al doble de largo ajá entonces por eso
este paralelogramo tendrá cuatro veces
el tamaño y ahora por eso estamos
normalizando esto porque estamos
pensando en términos de vectores
unitarios vectores unitarios tangentes
en toda la curvatura entonces si cortará
los vectores para que tengan una
longitud de 1 es decir tomar al vector
de la primera derivada y lo divides
entre su propia magnitud o su propia
norma y de hecho similarmente para el
otro vector porque quieres todo a la
misma medida que todo tenga la misma
escala
entonces el paralelogramo resultante nos
da más información de qué tan
perpendiculares están estos dos vectores
unitarios sin importar qué tan largos
estén y este vector es el de la segunda
derivada normalizado no con el mismo no
con el mismo sino como estamos haciendo
todo a escala lo dividimos entre la
norma del vector de la primera derivada
entonces éste
cruz / el vector s prima normalizado por
el mismo por el vector s prima
producto cruz con el vector s b prima y
a éste lo ponemos a escala del mismo
valor entonces lo dividimos entre la
norma de s prima esto nos da una mayor
precisión de qué tan perpendiculares son
los vectores de la primera derivada y de
la segunda derivada y no normalizamos al
vector de la segunda derivada porque así
así fuera el caso y la segunda derivada
no fuera necesariamente de longitud 1
bueno eso no importa tanto porque eso
simplemente nos dice que el vector
tangente gira más rápido ajá y de hecho
toda esta expresión es la derivada del
vector unitario tangente t con respecto
al parámetro t ahora ya había hablado
sobre esto en vídeos anteriores no
recuerdo si fue el anterior o el
anterior a ese que cuando buscamos la
derivada de este vector tangente con
respecto a la longitud de arco la manera
de calcular esto es primero tomar la
derivada con respecto al parámetro lo
cual
es posible pues todo está expresado en
términos de ese parámetro y luego lo
dividimos entre el cambio de la longitud
de arco con respecto a ese parámetro que
es el tamaño del vector de la primera
derivada entonces si todo esto es la
derivada del vector tangente con
respecto a t cuando tomamos esto y lo
dividimos y lo dividimos todo entre la
norma de s prima eso nos dará la
curvatura eso es curvatura eso es
curvatura aquí ves la magnitud de ese y
también aquí ves la magnitud de ese y
aquí también y bueno como la vemos tres
veces lo pondré en el denominador pero
lo voy a elevar al cubo
entonces la magnitud de ese prima pero
elevada al cubo y en el numerador pongo
ese prima producto cruz con ese mi prima
esta es otra fórmula para curvatura
hasta ahora hemos visto varias
regresemos a la original veamos la
original
aquí tenemos la original observa lo que
hay en el denominador si tomamos x prima
al cuadrado más ye prima al cuadrado y
le sacamos raíz a eso eso sería la
magnitud de la derivada pero la elevamos
al cubo eso está expresando esta idea
estás tomando el producto cruz entre la
primera derivada y la segunda derivada y
como lo estás normalizando con respecto
a la primera derivada quieres poner a
escala la segunda derivada para que así
el paralelogramo se encoja y todo se
mantenga en posición y una vez más
estamos dividiendo entre la longitud de
arco básicamente porque la curvatura
debe ser con respecto a ese y no con
respecto a t y bueno espero que esto
haga de esta fórmula que parece un tanto
más complicada un poco más sencilla de
entender ahora aquí ya tienes varias
maneras de ver cuál es la curvatura de
una curva o cómo entenderla y en los
próximos vídeos veremos ejemplos más
específicos